you understand the mosaic of culture
about how movies sort of affect
everything
has it always been like that for you
yeah i mean
most of my most of my life i've gotten a
lot
of my markers from
movies and behavioral things
you know uh whether it was recognizing
that no one can slap me across the face
you know like sydney said
do you know what you just hit me did you
really just hit me across my face
see that comes that comes from there
that's where i got that from
because i knew as soon as cindy turned
around and looked at that man
that that was not acceptable
it was not acceptable so movies have
often given me
insight as to how other people may be
feeling
about things of course we're talking
about in the heat of the night
what i registered in that moment too was
the other actor that looked of delight
on his face when
sydney slapped him back i mean that was
that was the thrill to me because this
for the first time i felt like sydney
wasn't in the world as a black person by
himself
for me sydney was instinctual he was an
instinctual actor and when i watched him
i that's the only time exactly as you're
saying
that it was like okay you're not the
only one here you see the guy behind you
sees and he just his face said
everything
say good somebody needs to slap your
behind back
you know because you you know and i i
have to say
i love all those actors in that scene
because it could not have been an easy
one to shoot
you brought up sydney and you know got
to ask you what it was like if you
remember seeing him
win the oscar what what your memory is
of that yes i remember my mother and my
brother and i
jumping up and down just jumping up and
down it's like wow
our guy one the winner is sydney
portland
and it's because we love sydney it's
just because we love the actor
and then later on i sort of understood
the
the weight of what he had done
because it is a
long journey to this moment
i am naturally indebted to
countless numbers of people but i didn't
understand it at the time i just knew we
loved sydney
you